[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue inférieur de caralp summer
m
hamel servi
drôle et sexy à lapointe bruno gaccio
[Applaudissements]
focus rs de francs mais n'oublions y
avoir au matin et mouloud achour
[Applaudissements]
bravo connaissez le principe les deux
équipes de personnalités vont
s'affronter sur le thème qu'elle préfère
elle même
l'enjeu est simple l'équipe gagnante
aura le droit de faire plus de promo que
l'autre première épreuve le bio quiz
[Applaudissements]
alors chacun d'entre nous va faire
l'objet de deux questions sur sa vie ce
sera l'autre équipe de répondre chaque
bonne réponse rapporte 1 point on
commence avec vous une occasion et donc
bruno et mouloud c'est à vous de
répondre
attention bruno est né et a grandi à
saint-etienne il s'est mis un temps au
vert dans la drôme après avoir fait
quelques bêtises de jeunesse sur
lesquels reposera le puits il a débarqué
dans la capitale
qu'est ce qui a fait venir bruno gaccio
à paris pour la première fois philippe
bouvard un job de vigiles des essais de
footballeur au psg ou une prostituée
philippe brard
jordi la prostituée manquant même nom
philippe bouvard filipova way
non non une crosse
tituber jeu tu vois je suis je suis
désolé je t'avais pas dit jeudi win la
prostituée était amoureux non non c'est
une c'est une fille que j'avais
rencontrée dans une station de sports
d'hiver qui m'a dit viens me voir à
paris je suis arrivé à paris et a
compris ce que je suis allée chez elle
et j'ai compris en arrivant chez elle va
trois jours après sa cruelle mais des
filles
excusez moi mais
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on peut dire c'est bruno gaccio
quand il vient dans cette émission à
chaque fois on révèle des trucs
absolument inferno et on a tout fait oui
mais là c'est quand même le plus le plus
soft
oui ok alors bruno gaccio question sexe
est un expert avec un avis très tranché
selon bruno gaccio on peut être hétéro
et avoir bon goût habiter dans le marais
écoutez mylène farmer ou ne pas être
étranger à l'homosexualité
ne pas être étranger la musique
alors soit vous connaissez bien ma vie
soit s'appuie sur mon visage et là j'ai
un problème c'est peut-être me suis tu
avais je suis super soft un homme
ne pas être étranger à l'homosexualité
je pense que tout le monde étant
actuellement je pense que tout le monde
est bisexuelle certains passent nos pas
d'autres non oui mais c'est un désastre
maintenant
la prostituée et mylène farmer sort et
fait beaucoup quand même
[Applaudissements]
alors comment ça s'est passé j'ai essayé
ça t'a pas plus bas voilà c'est pas ta
pas c'est pas ton truc c'est le passé et
a rien de compte allonger pour elle même
pire que celle là c'est pire que ça je
regrette de ne pas l'être non mais c'est
vrai mais enfin tu te retrouves sur une
île déserte entre coincé entre massimo
gargia et et amel par exemple et tuer et
tuer 100 % homosexuels ouais tu fais
quoi tu es dans la même merde noire même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si teddy nordnet c'est enfin moi j'ai
essayé quand j'avais 18 ans et s'est
très mal passé mais c'est vrai moi ça
s'est pas mal passé mais juste que c'est
pas du tout bien
moi je n'ai pas encore essayé j'ai juste
pris des chats là je fait étape par
étape s'est dit ce soir
troisième question
oui non et mouloud vous continuez à
jouer mais cette fois avec la vie d'amal
alors c'est dans les agités du bocal sur
france 4 que le grand public a découvert
à neige
comment s'appelle la présentatrice du jt
kamel chadi campé dans les agités du
vocal
mulunda son
zoom zoom
rachida darti new delhi gac couscous
zouzou faisons nous connaît par coeur
ouais trail comme mzuzu web avec
quelques titres
[Applaudissements]
hamel et toute mince pourtant elle aime
la bonne bouffe
quel est le plat préféré d'amelle chahbi
le cassoulet halal là bas il ya halal la
choucroute halal ou la côte de porc
halal
paella
la tête à être sur le cassoulet
non sur le phare halal pokerface sa part
m
très complexe très très dur ouais notre
réponse j'ose pas la chose par jose par
email
bella mais non c'est la choucroute
food halal c'est vrai j'adore un nom
mais la vérité non mais quoi deux
ambitieux
de la volaille les ambiances inquiète
donc le score et 2,2 points pour vous
[Applaudissements]
doucement comme on dit mais
qu'est ce que t'as tatoué sur tombe
assez des antisèches mais c'est pour
tout ça m'a passé
alors on continue avec vous bruno
guillon hamel bruneau c'est à vous de
répondre ok alors bruno s'est fait
connaître à la radio sur nrj vischer
virgin sur fun radio en télé il a sévi
entre autres sur tf1 nrj tps star tu as
table un comédien
quelle émission bruno guillon at il
présenté sur tps star avec manu payet
genou le morning le meeting le soir hig
ou le nuit qui
on est d'accord
c'est
lui
briefing dominique farrugia les bacs
vous faites le morning on va appeler ça
le soir heinze a duré 37 tonnes en
émissions way et l'émission l'émission a
duré un an jusqu'à ce que canal rachète
tps star
et après voilà après la drogue
certains d'entre vous ont probablement
des formules magiques porte bonheur
quels mots bruno guillon at il longtemps
décrié avec sa bande
avant une émission pour se porter
bonheur banzaï
ornithorynque ya là où verges
[Musique]
soit
six mois s'écoulent
franchement bon c'est pas possible non
il a
alors dit le battait
[Applaudissements]
c'est revient à la base la première
mouture du nord me composé sur nrj
c'était avec entre autres jonathan
lambert et c'est jonathan qui avait qui
avait instauré le large avant qu'on
commence donc à chaque fois avant
d'ouvrir le micro on faisait verges
bon étaient déjà ouverts c'est ça mais
après duke on le faisait à l'antenne
voilà ouais de bon goût oui monsieur
classe est bonne aloi la bonne adresse
d'accord on termine avec la vie de
mouloud mouloud est un garçon très
sensible
un
canard
comme toi thierry question selon son
blog qu'est ce qui fait pleurer mouloud
achour chaque jour depuis des années à
sa balance
voir sa collection de baskets air jordan
complète la disparition des dernières
keane en france où les questions
d'ariane massenet dans le beau journal
o mon petit plaisir j'ai envie de te
répondait mais c'est pas ça s'est
vraiment produit ces petits là c'est
quoi alors qu'il fait pleurer la
disparition des burger king hu
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini cette époque
marie à saint nazaire allait revenir on
s'est tous réveillés il n'y a jamais
rien qu est-ce qui avait plus que burger
king paul mcdonald si vous fumez de
bâtard là un petit truc
que tu peux vous redéfinir pour le
cuisinier que je suis le fumé de bâtard
tu ne manges fait albatar
[Applaudissements]
si vous vous levez un agent beau cinéma
ils devront changer la france
parmi ses fils un peu pourri
[Applaudissements]
le choc des titans
cyprien à l'habitat non shelton m'a dit
non pour un laps de temps non mais moi
je n'ai vu ça alors c'est pas méchant
mais le show de v6 dans six langages
ou la syrie y ont été tués mais oui
c'est eric hahn
woods a non sheitan il est très ami avec
moi non elle a dû jouer dans
non mais vanel champions je n'ai vu
sneijder a dit mme champions
écoutez fun c'est
non mais son image avait il pas les
droits de dents alors c'est halal police
d'état
[Musique]
le choc des titans
en tant que grand fan de mythologie
grecque ouais et de films hollywoodiens
je suis très fier d'avoir joué dans ce
film est chez tam c'est le film de kim
chapiron qu'à montréal français avait en
fait c'est surtout s'il présente sur
glace ouais ouais
cyprien de david charhon
ouais la vigie du bio quiz des scores
sont de 4 po et de deux pour euros
on continue avec la deuxième épreuve le
duo queen's
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors si vous lancez une affirmation et
vous devez me dire lequel des membres de
l'autre équipe cela concerne ou bien
aucun des deux
chaque bonne réponse rapporte un point
on va voir si vous les connaissez bien
on commence avec vous amer et bruno
attention vous êtes prêts parmi vos
adversaires qu'ils aient eu la chance de
travailler avec flavie flament
[Musique]
où l'on trouve aucun des deux voilà la
vie flammes
mouloud regarde pas dans les cieux mon
coeur fait le mouloud regarde moi dans
les yeux non mais des regards manche
dans l'émission
la famille
[Musique]
nourrir 19 et
regarder 2
c'est sandrine quétier
[Applaudissements]
on a toujours tiré
j'ai fait une émission avec les flamands
laisse tomber je te jure ouais bah la
jda voulons mais voilà je vous dis matin
cet homme plutôt que de payer un psy
voilà on a profité de brûlots je me dis
ouais je peux l'avouer pour pour flavie
quoi voilà oui oui alors
on et scanne le point on vous laisse le
point parce que là c'est la faute de la
production qui s'excuse compris de
flêtre
parmi vous avez acer qui a eu une
aventure avec sandrine quétier de le
dire
une aventure une aventure
qu'est ce que tu appelles une aventure
une aventure professionnelle
c'est-à-dire connu de vie tu as raison
moi je pense quelle aventure c'est dans
ce sens là mais bien de le dire nous
vêtir un million dont bruno guillon
[Musique]
et aucun autre sur moi moi j'étais
chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
non
ya eu une avancée une aventure
avec un canard mais bon je suis pas
d'accord quoi mais il ya une aventure
professionnelle tombé à une aventure
chez moi c est qu
parce que moi je vais pas où j'étais
si l'on n'aurait pas évoqué des
prostituées
oui la drogue et
le champagne
[Applaudissements]
parmi nos adversaires
qui devait jouer dans u
[Musique]
mais c'est pas pour faire une lecture
croisée des jouets non non
non c'est pas
aucun des jeux des titans c'est vrai oui
ça c'est vrai je l'aï combattu des
scorpions j'vois l'appel géant matin
mais ça à faire marcher le bateau fait
tous redoutaient 100 dollars en un
week-end grâce à mouler 100 millions de
gentil tu arrêtes de l'enclavé
les enfants réduits non pas tout alors
qu'il devait jouer lors luc
interactif devait jouer heureux que moi
je
devais me marier brigitte bardot et
jeanne ans sauf qu'ils attendent sauf
que l'un ou l'autre après le casting
il devait donc
non
tu es sans
alors reçu bon boulot mais si vous
décidez vous regarde moi un feu dans les
yeux j'en ai marre
voici après il se transforme ça les
moeurs
[Applaudissements]
ah oui bravo
c'est parce que mouloud et intérêts à la
louis leterrier donc c'est clair c'est
pire que faire le casting c'est que je
suis allé sur le tournage et je me suis
endormi ah ouais ouais comment ça mais
je devais faire une scène et cadeaux à
norton on passait en voiture et ouais en
fait une ville où toi je me suis endormi
los angeles
bon je vais croiser d'année dernière à
100 millions de dollars le week-end ça
peut poser lui louis d'or
alors conçu répond la jeune fille soit
sandrine quétier
parmi les adversaires qui est le cousin
de stéphane guillon alors bon il y aura
un piège
il s'appelle guillon votre il s'appelle
paul guillon fait que stéphane guillon
est kabyle
[Musique]
aucun des deux aucun et de
ses fans qui ont dit sans arrêt et un
cousin de bruno guillon sur après il
s'en vante
dormez-vous adversaire qui a déjà payé
pour avoir une relation sexuelle mais
deux
c'est à une amie à moi je vis tu as fait
voilà les deux ça n'existe pas c'est
soit l'un soit l'autre soit au canada
non
commune de biars cère qui est pote avec
je le crois pas valérie damidot à bâle
est bon il est super sympa et super
sympa mais franchement je pensais pas
que l'un des deux moi j'irai mouloud la
connais elle est super sympa bravo
voilà le score de 8 à 2 mais en même
temps vous en revanche
attention
hormis les adversaires qui a déjà été
gardien ou gardienne de chèvres
au coeur et le world poker fight fait au
déblai
gardien ou gardienne de chèvres
aucun des deux c'est bruno gaccio
[Musique]
à saint-etienne
il faut dire aussi parce que ça met plus
un secret bruno a fist et une chaire
d'histoire je pense qu'il y avait le
chevreau et est mort donc bruno est allé
le chercher le chemin est ce qu'on
raconte sur ouais c'est ça c'est très
bon ce soir est il sait ce qu'il
[Applaudissements]
a fait
en gros
c'est pas les repères regard des
missions tu dis que j'ai autant
parmi vous avez un cercle qui a pris des
cours de clown
hamel
démonstration
était comment comme ça
j'ai fait une ici toi ah ouais mais
c'est vrai que tu ton et grands lui lui
je faisais grand lulu et bien sûr un bon
bout mettant des vrais j'ai fait ça
ouais
la méthode a une excuse à ton époque
c'est à la mode
[Applaudissements]
les adversaires
qui a déjà agressé un paparazzi bruno
renoult
avec 46 vols ouais il allait chercher
ouais
c'est l'époque de capian chazal non si
ça j'étais avec claire chazal non
non non non c'est parce que j'ai fait
j'étais dans une soirée et une nana qui
me drague mais honteusement j'aime
attendant la sortie elle met pas un truc
mais elle met un truc génial de drague
que j'avais jamais ouvert et à l'écouté
de la musique je dis vous écoutez quoi
elle enlève un truc comme ça elle me le
mettre dans l'oreille et on se retrouve
à saha et de danger c'est
donc réellement brasse et la photo voilà
donc elle me dit maintenant on va monter
dans mon taxi vous allez donc j'ai dit
vous allez prendre votre taxi moi j'ai
faut que j'aille voir le monsieur qui
est là bas je vais demander d'effacer
les photos au lieu de me dire oui j'ai
face les photos il a dit qu'est ce que
tu as je fais ce que je veux sur la
belgique voilà la provoquer il m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu vas faire je dis je
vais te casser le nez voilà
non mais voilà j'étais végéter sur une
dans une ambiance un peu bizarre c'était
l'époque où on m'avait suivi on avait
fait des photos de moi de mes enfants il
y avait eu un dossier sur moi ou pour
sur mon assassinat qui a été prévu donc
moi les mecs qui me font des photos de
moi et vaut mieux qu'ils me demandent
avant voilà près bien dans le plus beau
mariage
je traiterai ajouté un autre côté
mentionne parmi vos adversaires qui a
déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
[Musique]
non personne ne fait rien deux personnes
parmi vos adversaires qui a déjà joué
avec peter brook
je dirais bien amer
théâtre non parce qu'elle a fait des
trucs comme ça va
ou non ouais j'aurais dit bruno ainsi
aucun des deux
président de l'assemblée dans un délire
tueur fou de plusieurs brokers ont fait
les gitans il peut faire pourtant
times dans le choc des titans tu te bats
contre le score les scorpions géants
m'ont pas toi si un jour tu as des
problèmes qui gagne c'est moi toi j'ai
débuté ces bâtards
[Applaudissements]
moi je n'ai pas assisté
au concert qui faisait partie a cessé d
un premier auteur des guignols
mabono
des premiers non
non non la première dont le nom est
arrivé après
on ne la fait pas on mesure mal et
bien le saas est un gros piège dans glee
pour vous six courses est bonne
et on continue avec notre quizz
chacun d'entre vous va avoir 60 secondes
pour répondre à un maximum de questions
sur sa propre vie ça franchement si vous
laissez pas votre vie c'est compliqué
n'aura point avoir une réponse ont
commencé à vous en mêler bruno bruno
gaccio c'est votre tour attention ou une
petite attention tu es prêt
dans quel quartier de saint-etienne avez
vous grandi mon plaisir comment se
constitue la première pièce de théâtre
que vous avez écrite à l'âge de 14 ans
conversation de bistrot dans une cuisine
avec kouakou pied ou le cheat que vous
vendiez quand vous êtes doué mais bravo
ça m'emmerde pour eux
c'est pas sympa ah non merde tu es
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
du
tout branleurs qui se droguent je les
emmerde voilà tu mets n'importe quoi non
monsieur bazin bas pour mouloud ça pour
voir
avec quoi fabriquer vous de la fausse
cocaïne vous étiez et
4,50 eric douloureuse ouais
[Musique]
c'était des espèces de gélules c'était
des gélules comme ça qui se tissent
gaubert j'aimerais ça il en vend des
saints dans des festivals et des mecs ne
nous dû faire chier est a pas de la coca
pas de la côte non on n'aurait pas ça on
vend pas de s'attendre à de la coop si
j'en ai demandé qu hachette y voilà mais
qui partait était super content mais
voilà mais je vendais ça combien
c'est par l'école de samba locale mais
moi c'est un jour j'ai acheté du blush
en croyant que c'était de la rose de
shy'm idol lola je sais même pas ce que
ces conditions je veux de la bourse de
shenzhen
quelle opinion religieuse avez-vous
indiqué sur votre compte facebook
amouri c'est un truc comme ça a mûri et
xavier renvoie à maurice vous êtes fans
des verts ouais quand elles étaient
fondées l'aise quand étienne
tu veux passer
tu peux passer le 110 20 19 19 cela
prend
selon un sondage la liste en 2004 par
canal qui était la marionnette préférée
des abonnés chira et bravo dans tout le
monde en parle de qui avez vous dit
c'est un je n'aime pas sébastien
bras
[Musique]
c'est simple tu veux pas non non ça y
est ça va oui ça va carrément parce
qu'ils avaient été très mal poli avec la
maman de mes deux premiers enfants ah
oui et que moi on peut me dire ce qu'on
veut de moi mais pas des mamans des
enfants ont pas touché non pas la fin
mais ben voila voila mais on est très
réconciliés depuis ça va
continuer comme l
attention
je vais présenter la météo sur canal
qu'est ce qu'un anticyclone
je passe
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas idiot en même temps je sais
que c'est compliqué
c'est une zone oui dans la pression est
supérieur 20013 hectopascals et qui
tournent dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une météo
[Applaudissements]
il est engagé sur canal+ dominique
farrugia comment s'appelait le resto
italien à châtelet dans lequel vous
alliez très souvent lorsque vous étiez
vendeuse
[Applaudissements]
et comment s'appelait le chef cuistot
sa musique me regardes
quoi non mais il faisait bien manger
discuter beaucoup tu sais qu'il ya connu
toi on a tous connu le 10 mai tous les
libyens
qui vous a dit après une de vos
représentations très bien soigné est ce
que tu racontes c'est 07 chinois qu'il a
gagné c'est mon père voilà
il croyant vous sait bien qu'à
l'humoriste jouer le rôle du chauffeur
de salle dans les agités du bocal
mathieu madénian ben ouais
quelle est la profession de votre beau
père médecin gynécologue - quel est le
film que vous regarder en boucle
il y en a plein oui affreux sales et
méchants
elle peut mais bien sa vie
attention on continue avec vous monsieur
guillon oui messieurs ardisson
à quelle occasion vous êtes vous rendu à
l'elysée
pour la remise de la légion à dominique
farrugia voilà qui est commandeur de jeu
dominique farrugia avec commandeur
légendaire générique notre énorme avec
cela
avec alain chabat qui étaient là aussi
et qui dit à un moment et sarkozy nous
tourner le dos et dirait le problème de
dominique farrugia ses équipes est
beaucoup et sarkozy se retourne en
faisant monsieur chabat tout le monde
pète j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
le mec classe
qui vous appliquez le titre de votre
show sur nrj12 faites entrer l'invité
c'est michel drucker meriem la papy
qu'il m'a demandé c'est ça qui lui
demande avant
la grande différence mais bien élevé
gentil
dans le soir une qui a été la dernière
rubrique de l'émission
je passe l'interview picard wii qui est
paul henri denieuil le maire de
saint-jean-d'angély où tu es né
exactement quelles sont les trois films
de 2012 avec manu payet à la fiche
roptin avec le stress
il joue dans je passe je passe je
passais radio oui je n'embrasse je suis
pas du tout content je suis ravi c'était
évident que ça marche qui était
l'assistante et parfois comédienne dans
le swing géraldine nakache a fait pas
chier dessus explique géraldine makan
nom du tout elles le méritent aussi
amplement d accord qu avez-vous doublé
dans l'âge de glace 2 un e aide est un
phacochère genre
pas trop cher
m
ra de stars et bien sûr je n'ai pas
douté
on va terminer avec nous d'un sourd
est-ce qu'il connaît bien sa vie j'ai
une vie très flou donc à peut-être
docteur
différentes versions de vous avez en
vacances cet été à los angeles ne sais
pas
alors qui est la plus belle de toutes
les miss météo du grand journal
charlotte le bon ouais comment ça
s'écrit apathie wa frères
quétier vous avec faire en fac de droit
selon vos propres mots prennent un resto
la tantine et draguer des notes et des
mots qui remercierez vous en priorité le
jour où vous gagnerez un césar
à ma mère tout le monde sait quel est le
plus mauvais film dans lequel vous ayez
joué cyprien cyprien
david charhon ce qui me regarde je mets
ça
de nantes justement êtes-vous l'homonyme
un écrivain kabyle un bref les deux
souverains
vous êtes fan de traces usa comment
s'appellent les quatre tortues ninja
michelangelo donatello
leonardo et et raphaël et bravo comment
s'intitule et de finale et aime ton
corps mais kobe
[Applaudissements]
et voilà 24 euros
beau
on continue avec la quatrième épreuve
dames messieurs larbi quiz
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde joue en même temps c'est
une petite interview à ma façon quand
vous pensez avoir la bonne réponse vous
appuyez sur le buzzer devoir commencer à
vous amuser que buzzer rassurez-vous
toutes les réponses parle de vous il ya
une contrainte ce soir les réponses
doivent se terminer en
en
l1
ceux qui le font comme faisait elle
gagne deux points
je suis un exemple uni riez vous pas en
vacances en afghanistan en iran chez
auchan la guerre ok d'accord
quelle phrase utilisez-vous parfois pour
aborder ou draguer quelqu'un
à a non on voit qu'elle est en
revanche le sport
que dit on souvent de vous pas
maintenant
qu'est ce qui vous a fait le plus mal
dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu as fait ta maman
raconte nous attend
non ces histoires de prostituées moi
j'en peux plus
me sens à ma mère
elle est au québec avec son fiancé
laisse tomber elle a 77 ans vient de se
fiancer
cette famille
[Applaudissements]
c'est une pizza à la mecque à 65 ans
attention elle même serait temps de
répondre aux questions quel a été le
plus grand moment de votre vie
sur la toile sur la dernière ligne
droite
qu'aimeriez vous faire un jour
brosse à dents non non partant
[Applaudissements]
on à dire comment parler comme ça il
parle tout le temps que
ans quel animal aimeriez vous vous
réincarner
de mikros quand un
attention
qui rêviez vous d'être quand vous étiez
petite jument
[Applaudissements]
attention
qu'elle est l'adjectif qui vous va le
mieux
à la haye les corps et les guérés quant
à l'achat
curieusement sexy selon vous
du sang
[Applaudissements]
non
à l'islam
[Applaudissements]
quelle est la plus grosse bêtise que
vous ayez faite dans votre jeunesse
alors attention
quel est votre passe temps favori
rester dans ma branche
assez bien
[Applaudissements]
rester dans l'ombre sur le banc
qu'aimeriez vous mangez
du parmesan
[Applaudissements]
très bien très bien
trente et un pour vous
25 go
on arrive maintenant à l'épreuve reine
de ce jeu le music quiz
[Applaudissements]
vous allez devoir reconnaître
l'interprète d'un morceau musical
l'interprète même si la chanson ses
références à votre vie bien entendu mais
si comme l'interprète que je veux trois
points par bonne réponse donc tout peut
changer et là vous appuyez sur le buzzer
quand vous pensez avoir la bonne réponse
pour sion bruno ce morceau vous concerne
david
[Musique]
abo
non
je sais bien
l'ena et non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
com
oh
tom jones
le mineur gallois on connaît d'autres
chansons évidemment n'est celle là était
absolument inconnu si ça fait peut-être
man c'est pour ça que je les choisis
pour vous et c'est incroyable que vous
l'ayez reconnu je suis fascinée là c'est
la voie en l'apprenant je dois dire tu
me scotche attention à la dernière fois
sincèrement ce pour amelle chahbi david
starr ouah
trop même
son metteur en scène la peine magasin
monsieur
didier dit joey starr voilà formidable
bravo bruno guillon c'est pour vous
attention
david
magnifique magnifique
[Musique]
l'orchestration dyan warwick mais ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs noir week
[Musique]
oh
sourit
sa j'adore
par jour
suite
je m'attends forcément
chance
il
j'adore aux gens
il ça
c'est bien c'est classe car côté david
et baccarat une orchestration un peu
d'ailleurs noir est formidable c'est
vrai de ce matin évidemment dédié à
bruno guillon qui se lèvent le matin lui
attention ça c'est un morceau pour
mouloud évidemment
david
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chanson s'appelle le livre spéciale
dédicace pour mouloud olivier
et il a fait le chef des titans
millions de dollars en week-end arrive
là bas
c'est pour toi bono a way you are des
marionnettes de non je crois pas si bien
dire david
antoine et moi à baker
m
[Musique]
et
elle a quand même gagné l'eurovision moi
je vais me faire virer de canal a passé
deux ans à gaza je pense qu'il faut que
j'arrête là
non début je croyais que c'était marie
laforêt vieux truc chanteuse des années
70 personne n'est certain pour 110
chevaux bravo l'as rome
est quel jeu blanc
[Applaudissements]
chaud
arrive alors
sans vie retrouvé la femme dont 110 jeu
fascinant c'est son fils alors les
coudes encore un petit peu quand même
évidemment pas tellement
pas déconner c'est un jeu vif chaussant
michaud et oui elle chantait pieds nus
comme yannick noah je préfère quand même
se nicher alors maintenant la chanson
kyle spéciale dédicace pour le lion d'or
lac c'est tellement facile que si vous
ne répondez pas aux trois premières
notes directe joëlle allah allah
je rentre chez moi continue ton jeu
bon d'accord pas répondu juste pour que
tu pars tu fais mais attention non mais
là c'est fastoche david
je suis offert de payer chaque appareil
dutronc
six mois
[Musique]
alors maintenant c'est la dernière
chance on a les ponts mouloud mon ami
mouloud achour et ses fastes chien david
m
oui
ap
pas la loi
est là et là tout de suite on passait là
c'est terrible
46 pour vous
et 31 pour nous
c'est donc vous avez beau père bugeaud
gourmands
on attend
mais d'abord et c'est normal la promo
des perdants
c'est ça la vie
alors bruno la matinale de fun radio
tous les jours de 6 à 9
mollo de la séquence de limoux dans le
grand journal
même pas c'est fini
suivez moi sur twitter
way up allez on passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
j'avais six adaptation de la comédie
musicale américaine avenue q ui qui a
triomphé à bobino oui je pars en tournée
à partir des mois de janvier on va
retourner pour une quarantaine de dates
reviendra à paris l'été 2013 d'où cette
forme de livre qu'est le site roosevelt
2012 dans le site roosevelt de mulhouse
point fr c'est 15 dur très très très
remonté très pratique pour changer les
choses sans qu'on ait besoin de
croissance quand vous tapez roussel 2012
ya deux ans heureusement il s'est tourné
dès 2012 c'est bio de mouloudji et
maintenant alors cet été vous continuez
à cartonner dans la pièce un manchot
place ou emporter aux côtés de nouveau
fait annuler un très beau coup avoir
revient en octobre je vous invite à
venir nous voir parce que c'est un gros
carton ont cassé des temps c'est
vraiment en mode est venu me voir voilà
suivez-nous aussi sur twitter nous
diawara amelle chahbi
et là vous êtes les bienvenus
ce bond en a tant besoin en sabrant ça
fait du bien voilà
par quoi commence à jouer jean have we
prod il faut dire dans la nuit voilà
j'espère aussi matière
bon sommer début d'août nationale chaabi
bien sûr bruno gaccio merci à moins d'un
jour merci à bruno guillon merci à toute
l'équipe qui met les affaires ces
démissions et le byetta gibbs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu